let's talk about new york
let's talk about new york you know
there's a million people over a million
people right now in new york
remaining unemployed that's a big number
by the way okay billions of dollars in
budget cuts to essential
services and institutions are beginning
thousands remain eligible for state or
federal unemployment assistance
in this moment a fiscal emergency would
be a moral and economic failure for new
york's legislature an executive to leave
this money on the table
they're talking about the billions of
dollars economists urge new york to hike
tax on billionaires taxed on
billionaires progressive policies
advocates are ramping up pressure for
wealth tax in new york
as the state's budget hole grows and
neighboring new jersey already has
chosen to increase tax on millionaires
50 economists from across the nation
sent a letter to cuomo
and the state's legislators let
legislative leaders this week in support
of a proposal on two tax hikes
on new york's billionaires the letter
arrived as the legislator gears
up for a full session uh schedule that
will largely
revolve around resolving the state's
more than eight billion dollar budget
cap which is expected or worse in the
following years
look i mean there's a bunch of people
here involved that are saying we got to
do something about it
the economy say the analysis also
included in the envelope
to state leaders predicts an immediate
revenue bump to a tune of 23.3 billion
and then an additional 1.2 billion
dollars in subsequent years while the
pandemic
continues to clobber economic it's a
scary time to be over there
uh in new york new york's billionaires
increased their net worth
during this period from march 18 to
october 13
by 13.2 percent yeah it's unbelievable
you know i used to be 100
against taxing the rich the mega rich
they earn the money
it's their money why the hell should the
government come in there and take a
higher proportion of it screw that right
yeah
i got to tell you i'm flipping and i'll
tell you why it's because of the
zuckerbergs of the world and some of
these other
jokers these billionaires that got bited
and elected okay
this is what you wished for now you deal
with it i mean you did not know that
this was coming down the pike
and the other thing is how can you trust
the government to even do something
23 billion extra for new york they're
going to screw that up somehow you know
they just think low hanging fruit it's
not like there's some visionaries that's
going to fix
infrastructure or do anything like that
so i say go get
in california and new york tax all those
guys the google founders
eric schmidt dorsey all these biden fans
tax them
do it i mean since they were so in favor
of
biden and extra taxes and they're the
ones electing him
deal with the consequences and i'll say
another thing too did you look at this
panel of people that are recommending it
bernie sanders elizabeth warren these
are socialist
communists i mean calling the shots of
course they're going to want to take
all the money from the rich this is a
scary thing and here's the other thing
too if these billionaires still live in
a state where you're getting hammered
locally by your state taxes man that's
another thing i mean a lot of these
smart guys have already bailed
tom i'm confused by your answer so
you're the republican
who wants higher taxes on the wealthy
you're agreeing with bernie and
ocasio-cortez but obviously
you think they're socialists and
communists i
did not think you were gonna go this
direction i thought you would have been
uh
really really upset that they were gonna
tax the wealthy you're
you're confused these days trump's in
he's out
i respect i respect the fact that you're
not just going down you're towing the
company line
it's interesting i respect it though um
look
this is something that cuomo has been
talking about for a while new yorkers
have been leaving
uh new york in droves californians have
been leaving california in droves we've
seen silicon valley people moving
um this is scary i mean if you're
already living in new york
and you're a billionaire you're already
paying ridiculous taxes whether it's
income taxes capital gain tax
state income tax whether you're your
firm might be in new jersey
i saw one person who lives in new york
but their firm is in new jersey so
they're paying new jersey tax and new
york tax
something that you asked the other day
is at what point do you leave and this
is something that cuomo needs to
be very aware of you mean he offered
sort of jokingly like don't leave please
i'll cook you dinner remember that whole
thing
something that i do agree with tom that
he did mention something
that we've we've talked about the
k-shaped economy where the rich get
richer
and the average working person you know
is struggling and that's
exactly what's going on here um in new
york is that the rich have gotten richer
why stock market clearly why why what
why have the rich count rich and the
poor haven't gotten
why are the poor getting poor rich
getting rich for the most part it's the
stock market i mean obviously if you're
it depends on what you're defining as
rich
you know if you're the working class
person that literally has to show up
to work meaning you're a bartender
you're a waitress you
you know you work for the airlines you
work for in the hospitality industry
you're a
hotel front desk person and you have to
show up to work and your work is getting
shut down
i mean you've highlighted many
restaurant owners who have business have
suffered
this is out of your control these
businesses i mean you see what's going
on in california
those people have suffered tremendously
if you could work remotely
from anywhere and we can i'm sure we're
going to talk about what still
so what are you saying are you saying
raise taxes what is your point i'm not
saying that you should raise taxes i'm
saying it at what point when taxes do
get raised do these billionaires say
[ __ ] it i'm out i'm moving into
something
what do you do give them counsel new
york's listening right now
do you agree with sanders and aoc saying
raise taxes on the wealthy
i think in new york or what do you do i
think at some point
something's going to have to give are
you going to listen to that i mean this
is
this is why tom like i don't know do i
agree do i i'm
saying billionaires i'm not saying
millionaires should have their taxes
raised but these clowns yes
why why billionaires not millionaires
you know what because these people annoy
me
number one why because of how um
hypocritical they seem
how how a lot of these people own social
media companies have started social
media companies
these are new yorkers these are wall
street we're talking about i know it's
hard it's really hard for me so let's
see
but we can go through it why are wall
street people why tax
billionaires dub like as much as you can
but leave millionaires alone why why
tax billionaires but not millionaires
because i don't think the billionaires
would feel it as much as the
millionaires but believe me i am not in
favor of more taxes
how do you know that how do you know
that how do we know that how do we know
that tax and billionaires they're not
going to feel it as much as millionaires
are
how how do we know i'll just answer that
uh by what mark cuban said one time he
says there's no
uh describe the difference between being
you know a
you know a meg a millionaire that has
200 million dollars in net worth as
opposed to a billion
he says there's no no comparison i mean
you don't notice anything when you're a
billionaire so that's my
baseline judgment on the fact that if
they tax them for a few hundred million
more
they'll figure something out or they
won't even miss it yeah but how do you
so
so do you tax the guy that averages 45
minutes a game because he's the best
player in the league
and you tax him 10 minutes because he
can afford it and give it to a
lesser player is that what you do so so
but let me explain to you where i'm
going with you so you guys so you sort
of who's the best player in the league
give me the best okay so how many
minutes does the average 40 minutes 45
minutes ago let's just say average
it's not 45 it's 40 at this stage
they're trying to get them at 39 to 40
minutes 40 minutes okay
i think it's too much tax the
billionaire it's lebron you got to bring
him down to 30 minutes it's not fair for
him to get 39 minutes give the other 10
minutes to
a benchwoman but but the point i'm
trying to make is
here's a guy lebron is getting underpaid
i'm not a lebron fan you guys know i'm
not a lebron fan he's getting underpaid
he's getting an 85 million dollar
contract for two years that's 42 million
dollars that's 100 million dollar your
player
if ronaldo is getting a hundred million
dollar your contract this guy's got to
be getting a hundred million dollars i'm
getting it off the court but
go ahead it's not the point they're also
getting it off the quarter okay he
should be getting 100 million dollars
why tax to billionaire here's a guy that
spends a million and a half on his body
every year
now is he has he always been doing that
no at 18 years old he couldn't afford to
spend a million and a half
on his body but at 34 years old when
most of these
nba players at 34 that are kicking back
they've already made their 200 million
dollars or starting to want to
leave the league and they put on weight
their belly comes at all you're looking
at lebron look at the way he does
lebron to me is the same thing as a
billionaire is in new york okay
if a billionaire non non uh what do you
call it
a generational wealth transfer billion
i'm talking about the legacy
self-made the 64 not the not the 64
of billionaires are self-made just
everybody knows this 83 percent of
millionaires are self-made
64 of billionaires are self-made which
is what 36 percent of them are
not self-made set those aside say those
numbers again
64 of billionaires roughly is self-made
so two out of three billionaires are
self-made self-made one-third family
like a walton like one of those guys
that got the money from the family eight
out of ten
83 according to a fidelity article
83 of millionaires are self-made sick
okay your hope out there for all of you
did you get your money from your mom and
dad no no yeah you made your money based
on who you're live settlement you're a
you're a you're a self-made guy right so
this is the challenge this is the part
that we have to be very very
careful with because we typically
indirectly we will comfortably pass not
punishment but pass the pain
to somebody that is not us okay full
disclosure i'm not a billionaire so
i'm not here sitting protecting
billionaires so it's not like i'm
sitting here saying hey
why are you defending billionaires so
much i think it's more like
here's a question for me for me to talk
to some of these politicians about
hey you know poor these people that are
going through tough times
and they're having such difficulties
okay no problem
let's talk about them what's your
long-term goal for these guys
give me your long-term goal for these
guys say i'm poor say i'm not making a
lot of money
say i'm one of the guys that's
unemployed right now i'm one of the guys
that's struggling right now so i'm one
of the guys that you want to send to 600
a month what is your long-term goal and
aspiration for me
you understand the question i like that
question because what's short term you
can give them a stimulus what
is your long-term aspiration for me
meaning
if i yesterday two days ago tico i said
something to my son
bothered me on sunday we're at lunch i
said something to really bothered me
yesterday i told you nice i gotta get
out of here i went to school i had to
have the kid come out of class
for me to go sit with them and i said i
need you to look at me he's holding my
hands he's thinking he's in trouble i
just want to know you're not in trouble
i said daddy said something yesterday
stupid to you and i'm just here to tell
you i was wrong
don't listen to what daddy said
yesterday that is wrong
whatever i said to him it's a comment
there's nothing you would it's nothing
that you would jennifer said the kids
are saying
it's nothing that was crazy but i don't
want him to
think that he has to change as a human
being to win in life
right so i have to breathe life into my
kid
i have to say i believe you one day
can be dot dot dot and manage
expectation for life right
you're working with me when you came
over here i had to say what adam i
believe one day
you can be dot dot dot i cast the vision
kai one day
i think you can run one of our companies
invite to me you say let's put 510
million dollars into a company this
one day i believe right okay okay
politicians
to the poor people that are struggling
asking money from you you want to send
them
all these stimulus money what do you
envision me being one day
what is your goal with me tell me what
is your goal with me
it's a question is the goal for me to
stay in this situation
is the goal for me to constantly rely on
the government would you be happy if i
become a millionaire one day
would it bother you if i become a
millionaire would it bother if i become
a billionaire
would you be bothered if i become the
next zuckerberg from a poor guy becoming
a billionaire creating
a hundred thousand jobs would it bother
you if i'm you know
amazon jeff bezos and i create a million
job would that bother would you be
offended by that
my politicians meaning do you want
me to get out of being poor yes yes of
course
yes i don't know if the answer is yes so
you're saying you asked that to
politicians i don't think
they respond to that i'm asking them
what is your outcome how do they respond
to it it's not a masculinity a
republican
politician would say yes period yeah so
so then
so okay let's just say a republican
politician says yes so let's just say it
is yes
okay do you have a problem with me being
a billionaire one day do you have a
problem with me to have a racks to
riches story go from zero to being a
billionaire one day does that bother you
am i a bad person now i was poor
i had nothing you loved me because i
voted for you
i busted my ass i got out of being poor
you no longer have to send me a check
i take care of my family i take care of
everybody you don't wake up in the
morning saying we have to bail out the
bed david family
that's not something you think about
anymore i'm a billionaire now let's just
say
if i become a billionaire did i do
something bad am i a bad person now
am i like an evil billionaire rich guy
that wants to abuse me is that what
happened
are you sitting there saying thank god
freaking one guy at least got 20 000
people working for him
that we don't have to worry about paying
those people you know unemployment
who's the hero and who are we selling as
a hero so here
these guys are sitting around saying
well let me tell you new york is having
a lot of problems because of stupid
policies
based on the politicians deciding to
shut down all the restaurants
and these restaurants statistically we
can't show that people are getting
coveted from these restaurants
they could have worn masks we could have
set up a better situation on seating
but yeah oh now that we're struggling
because we shut down and through so many
restaurants out of business let's tax
the rich
where the hell do you come out with this
kind of a solution you made the decision
to shut down restaurants now you want to
tax the rich
how do you come up with these policies
trump sorry if
you are in a bad financial situation
right now new york is because your
policies suck
so maybe you have to take an inventory
of your policies
don't every time when you screw up
saying let me go tax the billionaires
because you know what the billionaire is
going to say here's one thing you will
never miss
i've always said this never in our
business
we have builders people that want to go
out there and build a business okay
you never ever ever
do anything to hurt your builders
and in the philosophy of the book of
barbarians to bureaucrats the guy talks
about there's a prophet
he comes up with an idea then there's
barbarians who are willing to go to war
let's go let's go do this i believe in
this let's go
then there's builders that are willing
to build something
let me build structure then there's
explorers we should go explore over here
to see if we can build this business
into australia
we should go explore this market then
comes the administrators
oh we should create some rules and
regulations which you need sometimes
then it shows up the bureaucrats and the
aristocrats you know who the bureaucrats
and aristocrats are
politicians these are the guys that are
sitting afterwards saying well now that
we're running a big company with all
this money here
i think what we need to do is spend our
money
who the hell are you you ruin every
company you ruin every city you ruin
every state you ruin every country
these bureaucrats understand who knows
what the hell they're talking about once
you go create some jobs for people
instead of going attack some
billionaires okay now listen you make a
very compelling argument for the
billionaires and here's my question why
can't they
say something for themselves here's my
problem emotion creeps into this okay
when you see something like this what
what's our reference point it's michael
bloomberg
okay who pumped 500 million dollars into
the state of florida to beat trump
why aren't they saying something
publicly that we want to protect our
money
we don't want to elect these people that
are going to tax us
even more i would like to hear it from
them and i don't
same thing in california you can't lump
the two in together but i wish there
were
a few more outspoken they can't
billionaires okay they can't okay you
know why they can't unfortunately why
can't
because it's gonna hurt their business
forget about a bloomberg forget about
bloomberg because bloomberg is sitting
in a wood situation bloomberg
is worth 70 billion dollars at this
point okay bloomberg you know what's 500
million dollars to bloomberg
it's the same as you having 70 000 and
giving five thousand dollars to somebody
okay it's not even
seventy thousand dollars uh uh uh
seventy thousand
no no no seventy thousand dollars are
you giving five hundred dollars to
somebody yeah
that's what he did yeah here's 500 bucks
bro it's okay hey man i'm running
something i got i'm doing a
run charity run can you give me some
money you got 70 in the back here cousin
here's 500 bucks what the hell is 500
million to a guy worth 70 billion
nothing i'm not talking about that guy
i'm talking about guys that are still
building
building so a lot of times these these
guys that are running a company they
can't say nothing
because anything you say will be held
against you
because most of the people that are
working for you are not going to be the
ones that are agreeing with this policy
most of their employees are saying tax
the billionaire
tax the billionaire what they don't
realize is hey you keep saying tax to
billionaire
the billionaire is gonna have to cut
some of his
employees let go of 20 of his employees
guess who pays the price you do because
the same person
queens business owners haunted by amazon
loss amid pandemic almost two years
after the amazon pulled out
from a proposal to build a massive
headquarters along queen's waterfront
the site is vacant vacant the same place
amazon's supposed to build and to many
locals the squandered economic
opportunities even more
painful amid the coronavirus pandemic
the site just sits there empty it's
terrible said donna
dreamer owner of mad at llc art gallery
and gift store
we're in the middle of a pandemic people
say if we only had amazon
we got nothing the world's largest
e-retailer
abruptly canceled his 25 000 job
producing campus
in february 2019 after being attacked
ferociously by aoc
and state senator mike gianaris so you
keep pushing me out i was going to bring
25 000 jobs minimum
minimum at 150 000 all of your salary
you pushed me oh now you want me back
so figure out who you guys want to bash
at this point well here's my question
for you
um and you made obviously a very
compelling argument here
um you know they've said if you're going
to become a billionaire you have had to
make thousands of thousands of thousands
of jobs
pop up out of nowhere right you've
created these jobs you're the
job creator right obviously look at
um jeff bezos like he could have brought
in
how much money how many jobs how much
salary into new york and now that's
evaporated that's gone
so it's so easy for someone that's
making 30 grand a year
40 grand a year unemployed to be like
tax the billionaires
it's so easy for the bernies of the
world for the aocs of the world
to just scream tax the billionaires
because who's going to be like
who's going to be as impassioned as pbd
and say no these are the job creators
this is the reason that you have things
here's the solution
here's the reason that if you do that
here are the ramifications it's just
so easy to scream tax the billionaire so
here's my question to you if you're new
york
if you're the bureaucrats in new york
and you're like look bro this is a
stupid idea
this is dumb we can't do this they're
going to leave cuomo is going to have to
cook them dinner what have you what have
you
on the flip side what's your solution to
that what's your solution if they if
they're if there's a
i want to find a way to get a billion
dollars for being poor
my goal is i sat down with one of our
guys this week
last week he's one of my employees he
sits with me
to tell me his vision of what dream he
has for what business he wants to build
you know what i did for 30 minutes with
the guy we sat and came out with a plan
for his dream to become a reality
he left fired up confused why is this
guy wanting my dreams i said why not
we're sitting a process in it together
with him right we're sitting there
talking to him
i have one goal i want you to stop
being poor and have your own money so
you can have a backbone
because the more savings you have the
more confidence you have the more
confidence you have
the better decisions you'll make that's
if you have strong character if you got
a bad character on the inside
you more money you get you're
problematic to the economy okay if
you've got a weak character here that's
why you first develop the character
then you help that person succeed in
life right so what are you doing in a
situation like this
number one question how do we minimize
people being poor so how do you do it
for example if you make a hundred
thousand dollar your income
i make 50k to me what are you
double your salary no no how do i view
you you ever remember when you were
making
man think about when you were making 30
grand a year how did you look at
somebody that was making 70 grand a year
that bastard
no but how'd you look at him you kind of
like do it i'd love to make 71 days
right
imagine you're making 70. how did you
look at the guy making 150
oh brother let me tell you figures yeah
it's cool man i want to get to
you may so at what point does that
conversation not stop never never
never said that never but it's always
well he can afford it
well he can afford it while he can
afford it while he can afford it
well he can what do you mean he can
afford it
how can he afford it you can't afford it
i want to increase your number
so for me if new york focuses on
what do we need to do to get the bottom
and the middle
off to a good start where they can make
money get them back working
get them back generating get them back
rebuilding their confidence then things
are going to come back
up you don't sit there and say the
solution to this because
taxing the billionaires is another short
you know quick fix it's not going to be
basically saying that you want a
bottom-up approach not a top-down
approach is that essentially what it
comes down to
it's so easy to say trickle down take
the money and just sprinkle it down but
you're saying look let's grow these
people let's grow their mindset so yeah
i get a text last night
i'm on one of my guys i get a text last
night from one of my guys i'm not going
to say who it is but i'll just
read you what he says to me so this is a
guy that's a very capable guy
and for many many years i've been trying
to see if this guy's going to get
emotional or not to want to do something
big he's not
emotionally good or emotionally
emotional in a way but listen everybody
needs some kind of an enemy to want to
do something bigger don't get too
emotional
not emotional the way you do i'm not
talking about like crying by the
cubicles
because by the one i'm not talking about
[Laughter]
so he sends me a message i love it how i
won the bet i won
but i'm the one but wait a minute when
people win they cry sometimes
it's a good kind of good kind very
impressive it was very impressive i
can't believe it so i'm talking to this
guy this guy's all these lunches
i'm trying to find an enemy i said the
right enemy for you
will make you xyz money per year he says
one of my guys came up we're
brainstorming on who should be our enemy
i said what's that
he sends me a message i said you need a
true enemy
one that creates real emotion okay you
when you generally have
like you know the whole thing we're
talking about earlier this morning with
logan paul and
mayweather and then jake paul and all
that stuff and jake paul's calling out
connor
and the only person jake paul follows on
instagram is conor's fiancee which is
very weird dirty movement oh that's
hilarious
yeah it's a hilarious yeah so so now you
but but that's a
fake hollywood yeah you give a good like
majorga de la hoya it's a
real enemy like how jordan would create
the enemy it's a real
if you got a real enemy good things will
happen so he finally says to me
pat i'm really getting sold out on my
best version my enemy has become a
negative media that perpetuates hate and
lies
to build uh to people to build division
lack of understanding when it comes down
to economic principles and laws morality
abortion i want to find ways to make
change in homelessness at an all-time
high being worse and worse
he's going through it so i ask him a
question what kind of emotion does it
produce
he said fire purpose level of anger
frustration desire to protect
lead and teach god i spoke to the other
leaders
and i couldn't stop pat i couldn't stop
he texts me i got emotional about it i
can't help
this is not an emotional guy right okay
i want to get low-income
and middle-income families to get
emotional
about their dreams and their purpose
it's such a basic fundamental thing that
we're talking about here
but if i get the bottom in the middle
excited about their dreams becoming a
reality
you'll be able to get rid of a lot of
these issues that we're dealing with
if you get middle and low income
families excited
about their dreams become a reality look
i've said this for the last
first time i started talking about this
in this method was march of 2008.
one time i got on stage i was speaking
in front of 7000 people in las vegas and
i was given this message i'm 28 29 years
old and i'm talking exactly about
this language there's a difference
between a politician speaking a
nightmare language versus a dream
language
a dream language to me is mesmerizing
a dream language energizes people a
dream language gets me to want to
improve a dream language gets me to want
to get up and read a book
a dream language gets me to want to
figure out a way to get better like what
canadian used to talk yes
i'm talking we need and by the way even
obama talked to dreams when he was
giving his first speech
reagan talked dreams it's dreams we need
people dreaming again and we're not
doing that you don't just say
hey here's what we got to do now let's
dream again
yeah okay couple things um you know
cuomo's philosophy is tax everyone he's
even saying taxes have to go higher in
the middle of himself
he totally is but i think we give these
politicians too much credit right now i
don't
especially in new york i don't think any
of them are thinking big picture like
you're saying
i think that's why i'm so ticked off and
annoyed because
they're trying to get to a one-class
system in this country the way it seems
and that's not about creating your
dreams and
and making something of yourself it's to
be more dependent on the government
and my problem with billionaires is the
perception of so many of them
who went so far over the top to try to
get a biden who i lump into it with the
rest of these new york politicians that
just want to tax everybody
you know make it you know make you more
reliant on the government so some of
these billionaires i know they can't
really say anything because they have
big businesses
but the ones that talk the most give you
a bad perception
it's bad marketing about the billionaire
brand it's hard to root for them
because when they are so adamant about
trying to get biden
in and destroy a fellow billionaire
donald trump
it doesn't make sense it doesn't create
a lot of sympathy for them and it's hard
to understand
them i see what you're going i see what
you're saying i you know
again this is new york we're talking
about let's let's focus on this a lot of
the billionaires you're talking about
are the
zuckerbergs of the world and the tim
cooks of the world and the silicon
valley
that that's not these billionaires a lot
of these hedge fund billionaire types i
assume
a lot uh did vote for trump especially
uh regarding corporate taxes so let's
not just like
billionaires they're all democrats i i
doubt that maybe the silicon valley has
type people
um so but i never said that i i said
what they're saying doesn't jive
with what their end game should be for
being that wealthy
well by the way just so you know
facebook is in a very dire situation
right now with biden's camp wanting them
to
separate the entire company up with
whatsapp and instagram all of them
so so break it up oh yeah i mean your
policies
got you the candidate that you got now
they have to break you up and
now guess what happens next what happens
now is hey
we can break you up if you don't listen
to us so you better. so now this is what
it goes
it's not just guidance camp that's
looking to break up facebook 46 state
attorney general i don't think i know
what i'm trying to do no no what i'm
saying to you yeah but didn't happen
no it's actively going on as we speak
it's yeah but it's been actively going
on for a long time now with what these
guys are doing
now they're going to be able to break
these guys up but will they break them
up
i will be very surprised if those guys
are broken up
very surprised if those guys are broken
up very if they're broken up
more power to you if they are well
something that i know that you're not a
fan of are monopoly i'm not a fan of
money
here's the other thing to consider how
much does china want them to be broken
up because they're going to have a say
in it as well
[Music]